[Music]
well luke here with the outdoor boys
youtube channel
and we are going to alaska but first
i've got to pack all of this yeah
well the airlines is going to eat
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
good
[Music]
well guys it took us nine hours but
we're here in anchorage alaska and we're
so tired
i'll see you guys in the morning well
good morning everybody
the whole family's up nice and early
because of the time change we're staying
here at my sister's house which is
conveniently
next to my parents house and uh we're
gonna be able to do a little family fun
and christmas celebration here while
we're also filming
winter survival videos and going on
winter alaskan adventures you guys
excited
yeah all right guys
are you glad to be at grandma grandpa's
place
well today the sun is supposed to rise
at 10 30 and set at 3 40 so we have a
small window of daylight
so my sister and her family invited us
to take the boys out christmas tree
cutting which is kind of a tradition
so we're gonna go help them go find and
cut down
a christmas tree
okay
[Music]
my older sister is infinitely more
classy than i am the moose is eating the
bushes again
yeah that's right keep walking come on
let's go get a christmas tree
all righty andrew shall we go christmas
tree cuddy yeah
let's not be very far away well we've
been stopped for about 15-20 minutes
because there's a pretty serious
accident that's cutting off both lanes
of traffic so
we're gonna see uh see what happens well
it ain't moving at all even if we got
through right now we wouldn't have
enough daylight to
get it done so i think we're going to
call it but we've had a great time
hanging out and chatting
well there's another car accident don't
be driving in the stone let you know
your business
that's right darling you're the one i
wanted
well we're back at the house
they haven't touched their backyard at
all we need to we need to write
something
tommy all right guys we've got some food
here from
soul casa which apparently is like a
korean taqueria or something
called beef tacos bloated tater tots
egg rolls kimchi fried rice look at that
i am so insane with hunger right now
this smells so good
well good morning it's a beautiful
sunday morning here in alaska and uh
it's we're just taking it easy we're
gonna do online church here in a little
bit
go to church be reverend put your
sweaters on do what your mother
says a fat
dad steamroller
[Applause]
all right now that we've all settled
down let's go to grandma's house for
church
we're going to grandpa's house
i've been tortured all right
well church was nice but now we're gonna
go visit my brother
you know i've never done one of those
that's one minute
look at tom it's like a little natural
whoa tommy got almost taken out
well listen guys did you have fun at
cousin's house
we're doing our family christmas party
by zoom this year
[Music]
well we've had a great day so far let's
go get the kids in the car and go look
at christmas lights
you guys ready to see some christmas
lights
[Music]
[Music]
tommy did you like the christmas lights
well good morning we have a beautiful
week ahead of us
and me and nathan are gonna go do some
camping so uh
we better get packed
all right nate you ready to go camping a
snowstorm
check it out
[Music]
so
i'm trying to
[Music]
so
[Music]
area
[Music]
there you go you got to take your boots
off
we're going to put on your your camp
boots these will keep your feet warm
i got blanky time
got some reindeer sausage here
there we go some reindeer sausage curry
go ahead and hop in bed
how's that nathan you warm the boy just
bros in there like a tick
okay i am going to get ready for bed and
hop in my sleeping bag
maybe watch a movie or something just
kind of take it easy
[Music]
well guys i have slept better tonight
than i have in a long
time we slept 10 and a half hours
it's almost nine o'clock right now and
the sun's still not up
hey date you cozy yeah good
two thumbs up awesome eber i mean shoe
ball
oh yeah we got some snow up there
definitely got some snow last night
oh
okay
i've got some brownie mix inside this
mug we're gonna make steamed brownies
the brownies are almost done so we're
gonna get some ice cream to go with our
brownies
just take some of the fluffy new snow
here
just a little dab of vanilla
and sweetened condensed milk
if it's really cold and dry snow it
works a little better this is kind of
wet stuff
there we go vanilla ice cream
that tastes good tastes like real ice
cream
my fingers are so cold i can grab it
right out of the boiling water
there we go steamed brownie when you
steam a brownie it comes out just like
it was baked
only it's more moist you know what this
brownie needs
some ice cream
you like that i got i got a more
reindeer sausage that's that's my
breakfast
i gotta get you dressed
all right all right nathan should we
pack it up and snowshoe out of here yeah
you okay back there
oh nathan i'm tired how about you
let's go inside
hey that's it we intercepted it
[Music]
well it's just a nice relaxing day we're
just sitting here becca's painting and
my dad's watching the byu football game
that's going very well
it's a nice easy day all right guys it's
dinner time and we've gotten food
delivered from
jeepney which is a filipino hawaiian
mexican
fusion restaurant we got a lot of uh
like pacific influence here in alaska
but i have decided to order off their
japanese menu here and i've got takoyaki
oh come here tommy have some octopus
balls not any of the filling
well hopefully when you get out today
and do a little ice fishing and do some
adventures with the boys but it's going
to be nice and low-key
are you going to paint with mama yeah
awesome
this looks great all right get in there
i don't know if you'll be able
to once i really hate little campbell
lake is the name of this lake
so uh i've never fished here before but
we'll give it a try
it's like bubbles it's the oil coming
off that oh there we
[Music]
[Applause]
well tommy said he was really excited to
go ice fishing but then he saw this
sledding hill and all thoughts of
fishing went out his head
well we're back at the house and we have
got some moose's tooth pizza and root
beer
i am excited about this we got thai
pizza there with a peanut sauce
apricot pizza and a reindeer sausage
pizza
titled santa's little helper i've been
looking forward to this as we got to
alaska
it's amazing it's really good spending
the christmas holiday with the kids in
bed snuggling with my wife
watching the mandalorian this is the way
[Music]
well it's christmas eve and it is a
wonderful time to bake lots of food
eats lots of food and do generally very
little
and we are enjoying it very thoroughly
my sister here who is also
an accomplished professional novelist is
also
making madeline's and cooking for us
mellie just dropped her new book
hearts and twine what what we might get
out and do some sledding and some other
crazy stuff but it's just a wonderful
wonderful christmas break
i don't know if i should open it up
hurry up buddy hold this
that thing's straight as an arrow oh
right towards the tree ha ha
they're alive mush mush dumb you ready
tom
you're ready
oh it's so nice that they're old enough
to walk up the hill by themselves
i'm getting too old for this stuff these
nice people over here have a dog that
likes to pull they're going to hook them
up to the sled we're going to see what
happens
[Music]
no
oh
was that fun yeah there dad let daddy
pull you up
[Music]
oh right boy tommy jacob
you guys have fun yeah
yeah what you know what stuck in though
don't get ready for bed
[Applause]
oh my goodness please please
[Music]
your baby yoda
[Music]
it's the hobbit
[Music]
who wants an extra present if there's a
nut in your bread
you get an extra present there you go
here luke
there you go
shirley temple brownie
caramel cream root beer oh nice
[Music]
tom you've turned off your targeting
computer are you all right
[Music]
we're getting off our butts and we are
going to go target shooting
with my brother and his kids think
oh that's so close
was that fun tom yeah one of the best
things i've ever done
smells good hurry up we're going over to
grandma grandpa's for christmas dinner
go go go there's one okay look at the
other ones
[Music]
all right guys it's seven in the morning
and we've got the whole family packed up
in the car we're headed to talking
because we are going dog sledding
we just drove by an accident scene where
a little sedan hit a bull moose
who said the car didn't look like
they're gonna make it
this slide here is what we call a
toboggan sled
nathan do you know what the iditarod is
it's a big race where they go from
anchorage all the way across alaska by
dog sled he's one he's won the race
twice
there we go buddy
is this cool tommy
oh these dogs they love it zombies is
fun
this is fun
[Music]
check it out yo this is the break right
here tommy you having fun
[Music]
every time i lean on the break they keep
looking back at me like
why you stopping us you jerk
oh look at these points
we were just doing laps and training the
dogs now
now we're going somewhere different
this is fun tomorrow
oh my goodness this is so much fun guys
pretty cool that was awesome he said he
he's won the ident rod
yeah he's won twice great lovely dog
did you have a good time yeah did you
have fun you had a great time
i'm so amazing i'm glad you came dude
nathan looks like he belongs on the tv
all right nate you ready to run the
iditarod david do you have fun
want to go do that in greenland sometime
yeah yeah i think we certainly should
i didn't crash
oh boy enjoy it boys because this is the
closest you'll get to dog ownership
we're out there it could be 40 50 below
for the last time
i assume they switch off dogs
checkpoints
check it out all these iditarod first
place trophies
second place holds up the cable box so
well thank you very much you're very
welcome oh that was fun
is that awesome yeah we gotta do that
again sometime
yeah excalibur is a big boy
yes let's let's grab one of those then
all right
that should do it me tommy and nathan
are gonna be doing a camping trip over
new year's eve so
i bought some big fireworks we're gonna
make it an interesting campout
well good morning me and ninja nate here
are going camping so we're up before
everybody else we're getting some
breakfast
and we're gonna get in the car you ready
[Music]
[Applause]
so
[Music]
uh
[Applause]
[Music]
we didn't bring sleeping bags or tents
but i did bring a buffalo hide
there you go got two buffalo hides and
that's what me and nathan are gonna use
to sleep on
tonight
oh i am tired and hungry and it's
already four o'clock in the sun setting
i think i better just get a fire going
and uh
maybe bust my lights out and i can keep
working on the shelter after dinner
all this big wood is soaking wet
you hungry nathan good because we've got
a pretty awesome dinner ready for you
we're grilling king crab legs over an
open fire
look at these beasts this is just one
claw
holy mackerel
you got this little jar with butter
rosemary and a little bit of garlic and
we're going to put this by the fire let
it get all melty and warm
got three packs of sapporo ichiban
instant ramen here
we're gonna add that to the boiling
water
lots of green onions in our ramen
there you go ramen noodles for my nate
that's a good ramen isn't it
yeah i ate a wolf all right we're gonna
put these on the grill
man they smell so good i can see the
juices dripping out of that one
oh look at the size of the
chunk of meat that came out of there
that's why it's gonna get messy folks
real messy
whoa oh that's so good
okay nate take a bite
i like it and i don't like it you like
it and you don't like it this is one of
those things that i didn't like was a
kid either
but i love it now
this crab has more meat in his thumb
than most
most crabs have in their whole body
some of this and just
oh i am so full of crab and ramen
noodles oh it's
so good hey nathan you want a soda melon
flavored
japanese ramen a soda
i like melon flavored soda
thank you
well to say i'm sore and tired would be
a gross understatement
but i did it i've got the walls up
and it makes a huge difference i think
i'm just going to collapse here by the
fire for a little bit i am so tired
but one thing i've got to do before i go
to bed is melt some water i brought
three liters of water with me and we
burned through it so
i better get that done so we have it in
the morning
all right oh i am sore and it's past my
bedtime but i'm gonna sit here and enjoy
a moose's tooth root beer and a warm
campfire
before i go to bed
i'm gonna call it a night and uh i'll
see you guys in the morning
well good morning it's about 7 30 a.m
and uh slept pretty well
it's a little lumpy so i i woke up a lot
and tossed and turned a lot
but uh we did okay got this fire stoked
back
up and letting the place warm up and
let's sit here and
think about getting up and making
breakfast
all right got a bag of steel cut oatmeal
here
add some milk and we're going to add a
whole bunch of honey
oh it's warm it's tasty it's filling oh
oatmeal on a winter camp out it's pretty
hard to beat
good morning nathan good morning
sleep okay you like some warm oatmeal
yeah there you go
oh these buffalo hides are great they're
so tough and warm
i think nathan and i are ready to go
home and see mama you ready to go home
hello this is snake of the snake
and today is his birthday and how old
are you
seven oh oh my goodness i am
exhausted we're gonna sit here on the
couch and watch disney shows the kids
and
eat wiki wiki donuts here
oh look at that beauty well it's jacob's
birthday today and he wanted to go to
the zoo so we are taking a nighttime
trip
to the zoo
[Music]
his eye is really good
[Music]
about
it's not the shirt jacob wants it's the
shirt
jacob needs
[Music]
he gets two cakes because becca's
allergic to chocolate so we have a
becca-friendly cake
and a jacob cake hey jacob how old are
you seven
six no no three you're three tommy you
ready to go on a big adventure tomorrow
yeah i have got to get to bed because me
tommy and nathan are getting up early
tomorrow
to go on a pretty awesome adventure so i
will see you guys
in the morning
it's better to milk out your nose than
pee in your pants
come on get in the truck all right we're
finally on our way but the roads are a
sheet of ice
all right guys we are here with jake
from how to alaska here if you've
watched
a couple of our previous trips we've
done some awesome adventures with jake
he's got a
fun youtube channel and i'll put a link
in the video description below
but we are going to go out and do some
camping together a little colder
probably than you're expecting yeah it's
all right
oh my goodness he's so sweet thank you
i'm good at killing baby dog what are
you
doing come on uh you can
jake this entire bag is just
firecrackers
okay oh look at those earlier
it's only 17 degrees that's why she's
not wearing the peep toes
there she goes
just be careful don't hit anything like
the dog
nathan's living his best life over here
toby was that fun yeah
all right
this looks like a gorgeous spot hey
check it out there's a otter slide
see you can see where the otter's been
sliding down on his belly into the water
yeah a little bit of fish
and poo there's a spring comes in right
here so that's where there's open water
so that's how they get it under the ice
i never wanted to see anything oh yeah
no important nathan we get out here
starts complaining about his feet being
cold i'm like why you have a pair of
negative 60 boots
i look over and he's not wearing his
boots he's wearing his rain boots
and it's about 10 degrees outside so we
have got to get him warm
i'm gonna put his camping booties on
i'm gonna get him in a sleeping bag with
some hand warmers
slide down inside down okay
get down on the thing and take your
boots
get in off deep as you can i can zip you
up you just stay there and get warm for
a second i need to
put the stove together
all right we got a roaring fire in here
and it feels amazing
my hands were getting so cold trying to
roll that
that titanium stick your boots here by
the fire
oh it is still warming up in here well
while i'm inside fussing with the stove
jake brought firewood and cody caught a
little trout look at that
a little dinner there
[Music]
cooking up those little salmon yep look
at that little guy
[Music]
oh my glass is fogged up
come on in you can feel the heat already
take it out in here it's nice
all right let's get some dinner going so
we're gonna be making a little korean
uh tex-mex fusion here with bubogi
fajitas
[Music]
i got a knife
[Music]
that's already froze little bubogi sauce
on everything
that's gonna be there i've got an idea
there we go korean bubogie pork rib
fajitas
oh that's good they're kind of sweet
instead of spicy
really really good best korean fajitas
you've ever had
all right guys we got some fajitas in
our belly i think it's time to shoot off
some fireworks what do you think yeah
oh three packs of roman candles
that was pretty cute yeah it's cold out
here this is awesome yeah
look
hey
that was awesome was that cool
frozen marshmallows look put your boots
down
look at that sucker is that did you even
cook that
not even brown on the outside i think
you just ate a frozen marshmallow you
know
i gave you a perfectly good stick
see you tomorrow
well jake and his boys just left to go
home and sleep in their warm beds
so it's uh just us down here tonight
well i got the door of the stove facing
towards my bag and i've got a pile of
wood
within arm's reach but uh i don't know
how much i'm actually going to use the
stove in the middle of the night i just
don't know if i want to be stoking it
all night long
okay okay all right tom
sit down on the buffalo high
it's pretty late i'm going to bed i'll
see you in the morning
we'll see how this goes
we survived the night well it was a
little bit of a rough night last night
around midnight
tommy sits bolt upright in his bed and
starts screaming his head
off by the time i get him down
nathan's screaming and crying
it took me forever to wake him up i had
to pull him out of his sleeping bag and
pat
frost on his face to get him to wake up
and stop
screaming and then tommy started
screaming again
yo about about an hour and a half later
we got everyone to stop screaming and
stay asleep
i did not scream yeah you totally did
twice look how covered and frost my
overalls are here oh his pants are cold
outside the tent it's negative 16
degrees fahrenheit
that's negative 26 celsius
oh it's cold today man we better get a
fire started out here
well welcome back yeah all right cody
you want to go
do some ice fishing let me get this open
for you
this is the alaskan fish finder right
here stick your face in the hole and see
the fish
it works you can see them down there oh
cody what do you got here look at that
beautiful dollyvarden right there
i'm gonna start chopping some wood get
this fire going
that's a lot of wood
we got a bag of scotch eggs
build your chair
[Music]
yeah caribou sausage right there folks
this is what the caribou cody shot i
love
him
there you go scotch eggs got a
hard-boiled egg covered in pork sausage
and deep-fried with ponco
oh it's one of the most delicious things
ever when it's warm
so you know like there's a difference
between the right
you like
who wants to warm up
you like that nate
get this in the water
[Applause]
did you have fun yeah well jake thanks
for taking us along we had a great time
we had any time
listen if you guys want to check out
jake's youtube channel check out how to
alaska i'll put a link
in the video description all right let's
go home and see mama
we miss you jacob happy new year becca
happy new year
oh we are too old to stay up to midnight
let's go to bed
well good morning everybody we're just
sitting here making some breakfast and
uh we got a visitor outside
we're eating breakfast and we look
outside and
yeah hi moose oh
he's coming towards it oh okay where you
shut the door
yeah you realize this is just oh look at
that
i think he was gonna take a go at the
window there for a second think of all
the views we could get if a boost
destroyed your house
no thank you happy new year first day of
2021
the whole family and aunt melanie we're
gonna go hike
a glacier let's get you in the car you
ready to go hike a glacier
yeah all right let's do it
we're here at the matanuska glacier and
this is negative two degrees so it is
it is a bit nippy ready i'm ready
[Music]
all right guys you ready
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
a great time well that was fun did you
guys have a good time
yeah they do summer and winter tours of
the mad news
glacier i'll put a link in the video
description to this tour
we're gonna try a reindeer wonton to go
with our vietnamese spa
reindeer jalapeno wontons nice a little
spicy
oh a little bit smokey though
well guys it's our last day here in
alaska and we are doing the slow
pack up but we've just had a fabulous
trip
you guys want to go get some milkshakes
all right should we come back to alaska
soon yeah yeah i think so
we got ourselves all packed and ready to
go and the airline canceled our flight
and now we're not leaving for another
week so
yeah hey better go find something to
film
we called up jake with how to alaska and
i said hey you know my flight got
canceled uh you wanna go camping again
all right we're here i heard you guys
forgot your eggs yeah we did
we always forget something who wants to
get the eggs they might peck yeah
the dark kid oh look at that big sucker
that is a
holy mackerel no wonder you guys got so
many eggs look at that
good haul salad right there
you ready nate we're gonna have a good
old time
[Applause]
[Music]
all right
[Music]
all right we got the ted set up we got
some firewood we're gonna drop the
trailer and take the snow machines up
into the pass
see if we can't find some rabbits or
tarmigan and uh
hopefully we'll have a little something
to cook up for dinner all right tom you
ready
yeah all right
[Music]
right now we're looking for tarmigan and
this time of year they turned
white so we're looking for an all-white
bird
in the middle of all this snow
oh there's one two three four moose up
there
i think we've seen like 11 or 12 moose
on this trip
nathan what did you guys do
i think you hit a tree
well it's been a little eventful getting
back to camp
luke got a snow machine stuck in a
goalie and it took a good 30 40 minutes
for all of us to get it out
and by the time we got it out jake's
snow machine had cooled down
and the clutch froze so it's not
starting
yeah we're a good hour or so into just
messing with snow machines
here watch out you don't want this strap
snapping back at you either
there we go all right we towed the snow
machine
all the way back to camp and uh we're
gonna get a fire started get some food
and get this tent warmed up
it's cold
you out want to back up this stuff scare
the place
yeah that's burning good all right nate
you want some chocolate milk
okay oh yeah okay
chocolate milkshake right there all
right should we get some dinner going
and we kicked butt which always hell
oh that smells good guys i think this
is perfect who wants a tinfoil dinner
here
the ingredients were kind of raw in
there the key is that italian sausage
man it's so seasoned
so well jake and his boys are gonna head
home and take care of that broke down
snow machine
and uh me tom and nate are gonna sit
here and camp all night
tomorrow we've got some fun planned i
think we're gonna try to go and see if
we can't do a little hunting
and maybe do a catchy cook we'll see
what happens
all right see you guys
you got a long way to tow that
snowmobile
here come on i got your beds all made up
guys
then i'm gonna hop into bed maybe watch
the show on my phone and i'm gonna go to
sleep and i'm gonna see you guys
in the morning all right nathan you
sleep well
yeah but anyway we're liking star wars
no man
well jake and his family were kind
enough to let us have some of the fresh
eggs their hens laid
we're gonna make hard-boiled eggs here
[Music]
i think we've got guests
good morning good morning we're mostly
packed up
you guys warmed up let's get ready to go
hunting but we're gonna get hungry so
i'm bringing some hot dogs
are you having fun nathan yeah good
there's one moose right there there's
another one over there
try to avoid the moose
jake must have saw something he's got
the gun out oh i think he's aiming at
something
oh there you go
one down man that's beautiful so we were
taking this zone machine up a hill
and hit the kill switch and the machine
died of course and we couldn't get him
turned back on something's wrong with
the machine
all right guys we've been monkeying with
this machine it looks like it's properly
stranded here
can you tow that machine out or are you
with that one or you have to get some
friends to help you
i can't tow it out with this one though
we're gonna squeeze onto two machines
and see if we can get back to camp
can we see if the hot dogs are done
all right are they cold or hot
lukewarm giving them another 5-10 miles
they would have been perfect
we gotta thaw our buns out we froze our
buns off
all right who wants one
what we got ketchup shave ice here i was
saying the other day
i've never
[Music]
our heroes we're saved we don't have to
cannibalize the children
aren't they so pretty so it wasn't like
he was rallying the machine or anything
we're working on this thing and see if
we can't get to get it running again
that's the way it should
that sounded promising
you ready to go home yeah
we made it back alive tommy are you okay
you tired
you're nathan your seat's over here bud
it is late and i am going to bed and i
will see you guys
in the morning well it's our last day in
alaska
for the second time but uh today the
boys are just doing their online school
and
i'm packing again getting everything
ready we're gonna do a few fun things
with family before we take
off
we got all the bags packed now we're
gonna head out with the family
go have some fun all right you guys
ready go to the movies
so we've rented a movie theater and my
family are all gonna go there we're
gonna have our own private viewing it's
actually
pretty affordable
there is no charge for awesomeness or
attractiveness
well that was a fun thing to do with the
family uh unfortunately
all good things must come to an end
[Music]
though
you ready to head back no
[Music]
[Music]
well guys did you have a good time yay
oh
and it's 46 degrees here in virginia and
it feels so
warm but hopefully you guys enjoyed this
video if you want to see
other trips we've taken to alaska and
other adventures overseas and domestic
i'll put a link to our travel and
adventure playlist in the video
descriptions
and don't forget to click subscribe we
put out new videos every saturday
morning
if you like this video don't forget to
check out the outdoor boys youtube
channel where we have hundreds of videos
just like this
and don't forget to click subscribe so
you can see other great videos every
saturday morning
and hit that bell button you'll get
notifications thanks for watching